früher 2020 immer häufiger begegnen wir
diesen buchstaben auf der straße
kyu im internet dahinter steckt eine
schier unglaubliche verschwörungstheorie
mit prominenten verbreitern kennern
anhänger glauben an pädophile eliten und
dass diese gedeckt werden von einem
feind dem tiefen staates in den
mitgliedsländern anhänger wie ines
donald trump der auserwählte ihr
verbündeter im kampf gegen die eliten
manche sind in dieser auseinandersetzung
sogar bereit zu töten
auch in deutschland gewinnt die theorie
immer mehr anhänger die sich in
telegramm gruppen unter sich führen
[Musik]
leider glaube ich nicht dass
sicherheitsbehörden die bedrohungen die
von kiener rausgeht auf dem schirm haben
wie gefährlich kann eine
verschwörungstheorie werden wenn man
wirklich in dieser weltsicht bewegt das
kobalt ja auch das letzte mittel um zu
verstehen wie kellnern in die welt kam
müssen wir zurück in das jahr 2017 auf
die seite eines imageboards dass auch
rechtsextreme für ihre propaganda nutzen
ein unbekannter nutzer gibt sich dort
als hochrangiger informant aus dem
engsten kreis um donald trump aus der
vermeintliche insider nennt sich kill
seine gefolgschaft qr codes für
anonymous
er beginnt kryptische nachrichten zu
veröffentlichen rätsel angeblich voller
geheimer informationen über donald
trumps kampf gegen eine große
verschwörung satanistische kindermorden
der eliten
was und wer steckt hinter dieser
verschwörung erzählung anruf bei einem
der es wissen muss der journalist und
autor microsoft erhält ist experte für
in den usa die nachrichten der
angeblichen opfer hinterlässt werden in
der szene als die drobs bezeichnet
wer außenstehende kaum zu verstehen geht
es ihr um das virus oder um die vielen
klippen wird am montag zwischen 7 45 und
8 uhr 30 eastern standard time
verharmlosen bis 30 oktober 2007 zu
flüchten möchte ich alles wird gut nach
der wahl welt ist das was wir hier
machen
wäre versatzstücke einer verschwörungs
erzählung was die botschaften aber so
erfolgreich bei ihren anhängern macht
sie schaffen kleine rätsel eine
verschwörungs erzählung zu mitmachen
die entschlüsse in der crew drops
glauben ein weltweites pädophiles
netzwerk in tann zu haben
ihnen geht es nicht um reale verbrechen
an kindern dies er tatsächlich gibt
stattdessen glauben sie angehörige der
elite würden kinder in unterirdischen
lagern foltern um aus ihrem blut ein
mittel zu gewinnen dass der elite als
lebenselexier die trainercrew in
deutschland verbreitet auch xavier
naidoo solch erzählung
[Musik]
die das entree dunk rom bilder
wenn ich das ertragen kann bekanntheit
erlangte adreno chrome vor allem durch
die popkultur in dem kinofilm fear and
loathing in las vegas berauscht sich der
protagonist angeblich anna trine chrome
menschlichen körpers reine fiktion doch
den verschwörungs gläubigen gilt sogar
dieser spielfilm als beweis für die
theorie und kinder blut es passiert
gerade erwacht die welt langsam oder
kennt das böse hoffentlich gibt es eine
liste von diesen leuten die man an den
scheiterhaufen bringen muss endlich
wachen so viele auf tatsächlich ist
adreno chrome schlicht ein
oxidationsprozesse von adrenalin kann
synthetisch hergestellt und einfach im
internet bestellt werden wie hier
man braucht also kein kinder blut die
angeblich berauschende wirkung von
adreno chrome wissenschaftlich
unbewiesen eine idee aus einer
romanverfilmung völlig unbelegt warum
glauben auch in deutschland menschen
daran
wir besuchen mehrere demonstrationen
gegen die korona schutzmaßnahmen
viele der teilnehmer innen verbreiten
verschwörungs erzählungen
manche sehen aus wie hippies auch
rechtsextreme sind dabei und dazwischen
immer wieder menschen mit crew zeichen
wie fragen sie was es damit auf sich hat
greifen
[Musik]
wir haben da einen schuh auf ihrer
kleidung können wir erklären was es
damit auf sich hat ja das muss ich nicht
auch nicht erklären das ist ja praktisch
erklärt
wer sich damit beschäftigt für die liebe
für etwas nicht einzusetzen ja und das
ist für mich die kugel wägung ein teil
von dieser dieser kuh erzählung ist ja
dass es hallo viele lokale netzwerke
gibt und das ist in assen das massen
doch kinder entführen und missbrauchen
und dann aus der jüngsten haben sie das
stimmt also auch hier
das ist natürlich eine sehr abstruse
vorstellung ja es liegt bei jedem selbst
ob man das jetzt glauben mag oder nicht
ja ich könnte es mir vorstellen dass es
so eine art droge sein könnte die wie
lsd wirkt da wenn dieses entree
noradrenalin mit luft oxidiert das dann
zu adriano chrome bild ein run auf eine
verschwörung erzählung die so abstrus
klingt
warum wir besuchen pia lamberti
sie ist psychologin und forscht zu
verschwörungs möge auch zu knapp
new york un und das ist so ein bisschen
wie der vielleicht sowieso prototyp
eigentlich ein verschwörungs erzählung
es geht ja auch bei verschwörungs
erzählungen darum sich selber zu erhöhen
dass das man vielleicht die person ist
die die wahrheit herausfindet und dass
sie so vielleicht auch so eine gewisse
heldentum zelebrieren können dass sie
vielleicht auf anderen ebenen nicht
schaffen dass verschwörungs mythen
gerade jetzt großen zulauf bekommen ist
für pia lamberti nicht überraschend
allgemein ist es so dass menschen vor
allem dann an verschwörungen glauben
wenn sie einen kontrollverlust erleben
plötzlich ist eine der partnerschaft
beispielsweise ein jobverlust aber eben
auch eine gesellschaftliche krise eine
globale pandemie wie wir sie gerade
haben können der faktoren seien die das
nochmal begünstigen die zeigen lamberti
unsere recherchen sprechen auch über
xavier naidoo mit ihren trainern ist
nicht die erste verschwörungs erzählung
der naidoo eine plattform trotzdem haben
fernsehsender im jahre lang eine bühne
gegeben haben zahlreiche prominente ihn
gegen kritik in schutz genommen
wenn populäre person wie du solche dinge
bewirkt das ist noch mal eine extra
gefahr also dass seine person die
unglaublich viele anhänger hat die ihm
ihr auch irgendwo vertrauen die ihm
vielleicht auch bewundern
als er im märz 2020 einen song kostet in
dem er stimmung gegen geflüchtete macht
verliert er seinen vertrag beim
privatfernsehen seither nutzte intensiv
telegramm auch zum verbreiten von
verschwörungs erzählungen wie tuner wenn
man jetzt bedenkt dass eben telegramm
ist ja gerade dass der kanal die am
meisten genutzt wird dass es ja auch
noch mal anders als wenn man
benachrichtigungen bekommt auf facebook
das ist auf dem handy dass es zwischen
privaten nachrichten vielleicht zwischen
familien z und der nachricht vom partner
taugt dann auf einmal eine nachricht auf
also ich glaube das wird nochmal
emotionaler und nochmal stärke der
verschwörungs content des sängers kommt
an
über 80.000 abonnenten volk leitung
richtig an alle interessierten menschen
da draußen interessiert an der wahrheit
ich habe vieles gesehen urteilt in
seinem telegramm kanal auch inhalte des
größten deutschen kennen kanals global
change diese botschaft richtet sich an
alle menschen für die diesen widerstand
symbolisiert wir brauchen ein
schmutziger krieg
wir werden uns nicht verstecken
eine kriegserklärung an staat und
regierung der kanal hat über 90 tausend
abonnenten auf youtube noch größer ist
der in der messenger app telegramm mit
hilfe eines daten experten analysieren
wir verschiedene telegramm kanäle der
deutschsprachigen canon scene
wer folgt ihm und was wir dort geteilt
unsere analyse zeigt seit mitte märz dem
beginn der korona maßnahmen in
deutschland haben die größten teile
gramm kanäle der szene in einem rasanten
tempo neue mitglieder gewonnen
auch global change über 100.000 menschen
folgen ihm dort die gefolgschaft des
kanals hat sich seit anfang märz
vervierfacht in unserer datenanalyse
sehen wir auch corona ist ein beliebtes
thema in der deutschsprachigen kinos
szene
sechs der zehn meist gesehenen
nachrichten des kanals global change
haben mit der korona pandemie zu tun
auch in anderen kleinen gruppen auf
telegramm ist corona eines der
wichtigsten themen beschwerden über die
masse nicht vermischen sich dort mit
lynchmord fantasien neben xavier naidoo
ist ein deutscher akteur besonders
wichtig für die verbreitung von panik
[Musik]
früher schrieb er für das magazin focus
money heute lebt er auf den philippinen
und arbeitet unter anderem für das
extrem rechte kompakt magazin
er veröffentlicht regelmäßig videos für
seine 146.000 abonnenten auf youtube sie
tragen titel wie die korona krise eine
satanische freimaurer inszenierung
wir wissen nicht einmal geschrieben eine
weltregierung an musikvideos dazu
gemacht habe ich auch schon die beweise
gebracht
oliver janich und xavier naidoo kennen
sich schon seit jahren die beiden stehen
im austausch
mehrfach hat der sänger dem blogger in
den vergangenen monaten interviews
gegeben
[Gelächter]
jannik und naidoo teilen offenbar ihren
hang zu verschwörungstheorien bereits
seit mehr als zehn jahren mit
verschwörungs mythen und einer nähe zu
rechtsextremen reichs bürgerbewegung auf
diese glauben deutschland seien
besetztes land und sie lehnen die
verfassung ab schon 2011 sagte naidoo im
ard frühstücksfernsehen
wir sind immer noch ein besetztes land
deutschland hat kein friedensvertrag und
dementsprechend ist deutschland auch
coversongs wie raus aus dem reichstag
von 2009 laufen auf rechtsextremen
demonstrationen
verschwörungs erzählungen sind für
rechtsextreme besonders wichtig sagt er
verschwörungs in dialogen und
rechtsextreme teilen sich zwei wichtige
erzählungen zum einen gebe es eine
geheime elite die zum schaden der
deutschen die welt lenken würde
zum anderen werden dadurch alle medien
gesteuert von dieser elite und man kann
nur der alternativen presse trauen
in diesem weltbild sind sie also vereint
prinzipiell funktionieren rechtsextreme
weltbilder nur mit verschwörungs
erzählungen ihre dietrich ist
rechtsextremismus experte sein job die
dunklen ecken des internets beobachten
radikalisierung im netz münde immer
häufiger in realer gewalt zu ändern hält
er für besonders gefährlich halte das
risiko von offline gewalt von kieran
derzeit in all diesen mächtigen will den
tatsächlich für das größte den usa ist
diese bewegung ja schon länger aktiv wir
sehen dort haben sich morde entführungen
terroristische anschläge gehäuft jetzt
wo es in deutschland eine breitere
masse erreicht hat wird auch folgen 2009
10 gab es in den usa zwei morde durch qi
gong anhänger einer der täter erschien
vor gericht mit vielsagenden kritzeleien
in der hand dem wahlspruch donald trumps
make america great again und einem q
auch in deutschland herrscht in kleinen
gruppen teilweise blanker hass ein
gruppenmitglied schreibt über politiker
mich kümmern die arschlöcher überhaupt
nicht aufhängen vor publikum alle ein
anderer träumt sich den putsch dabei
alle vereinen und alle nach berlin
kommen ja und dann diese bundestag
stürzen dann sowieso so weit dass
bürgerkriege entsteht
aber dann muss man provozieren man muss
brücken einsamer muss die regierung
stürzen
alle war yannis seinerseits droht
journalisten die kritisch über ihn und
naidoo berichten
das ist regionale gibt ich sag's immer
wieder sind die journalisten auch xavier
naidoo spielt in seiner musik nicht erst
seit ein paar monaten mit drohungen
gegen politiker
beziehungsweise volksverräter alles wird
vergeben wenn er einsichtig sein und
sonst sagte wütende bauern mit der forke
dafür dass sie ein wichtig sei auf
telegramm geht oliver janich im august
2008 10 noch weiter sie konfrontieren
alle war ja nicht schriftlich mit seiner
äußerung wollen wissen warum er zu
gewalt aufruft eine antwort bekommen wir
nicht xavier naidoo hatte sich in der
vergangenheit gegen gewalt ausgesprochen
wir fragen naidoo schriftlich bitten um
ein interview warum bewirbt der
ideologien die zu gewalt führen
und wie steht er zu ja nix gewalt
aufrufen doch naidoo antwortet nicht auf
unsere anfrage aus worten können auch in
deutschland taten werden
und immer häufiger bieten verschwörungs
ideologien ein anlass für terrorattacken
man sieht in deutschland an halle in
hanau aber auch weltweit an attentaten
wie in christchurch dass menschen
verschwörungs erzählung nutzen um ihre
taten zu legitimieren beispiel hanau in
einem vor der tat veröffentlichten video
äußerte täter tobias r gedanken die an
die kleinen erzählung erinnern
in eurem land gibt es sogenannte tiefe
untergrund militärbasen in manchen davon
huldigen sie dem teufel selbst sie
misshandeln foltern und töten kleine
kinder
man sieht sogar empirisch dass der
glaube an verschwörungen und sprechen
wir vom abstrakten glauben an
verschwörungen schon mit einer
gesteigerten gewalt affinität einhergeht
dass diese menschen sich mehr vom
demokratischen diskurs abnabeln und
stattdessen tatsächlich auch er
gewalttätige politische alternativen
suchen um ihre eigene wahrheit zu
verkünden um ihre ziele zu erreichen
in den usa stufte das fbi kennen schon
im mai 2009 10 als mögliches terror
risiko ein
wie schätzen deutsche
sicherheitsbehörden die gefahr ein
die solche verschwörungs erzählungen für
die innere sicherheit darstellen
wir fragen den verfassungsschutz
derartige verschwörungstheorien können
sich zu einer gefahr entwickeln konkrete
kenntnisse die nicht vor die bedrohungen
die von tiernahrung ausgeht auf dem
schirm haben werden das ganze jahr schon
mit den reis bürgern damals gesehen wie
lange diese bedrohung nicht ernst
genommen wurde und wir sehen darf auch
heute wieder
erst im april erklärte der
verfassungsschutz in sachsen gegenüber
dem mdr
es lägen keine erkenntnisse vor dass q
allen aktivitäten im freistaat fuß
fassten aber mit einem fünf minuten
suche konnte ich ganz schnell das
gegenteil finden es gibt auch telegramm
eigene touren und sachsen kanäle die afg
landkreis leipzig teilt 49 beiträge und
mehrere menschen in kleinen gruppen
erfahren dass die aus sachsen kommen
braut sich etwas zusammen dass die
behörden nicht im blick
via lamberti fürchtet dass aus der
kleinen verschwörungs erzählung auch in
deutschland gewalt erwachsen kann man
wirklich glaube diese dunklen nächte
sind da unterwegs und ermorden tausende
von kindern dann denkt man man muss was
machen und wenn ich vor ein paar jahren
vortrag gehalten habe dann war meistens
die reaktion auch verschwörungstheorien
die sind ja so lustig und diese reaktion
bekomme ich jetzt nichts mehr an das ist
nochmal echten effekt der korona panini
dass auf einmal das nah gekommen ist
wenn man das thema verschwörungs
erzählung persönlich geworden
[Musik]
habt ihr in eurem umfeld jetzt häufiger
mit verschwörungstheorien zu tun
wir freuen uns auf eure sicht und eure
geschichten schreibt uns in die
kommentare